おかあ先そこのセキレイ
サングラスをかけて出てくれば笑ってくれるんじゃないかという提案を受けましたけど
多分でうちになっちゃうのでやめときます
では僕の発表を始めさせて頂きますよろしくお願いします
皆さんは裕という芸能人をご存知でしょうか
こういう人です
お笑いのネタ見たことがあるという方もいらっしゃるかと思いますが最近では多くの
場合そのキャンプブームの火付け役として知られ多くのメディアに香らしています
かく言う私もソロキャンプというものを初めて misia のテレビ
その番組は裕が出ていたわけでありませんでしたが
その代わりこのようにですねオーダーや仮装で性格や来てババア払う厳しく男子ですよ
ねこの方が総合司会をしていましたそしてその番組でも言及されていましたが裕を含む
彼らの音ソロキャンパーつまりソロキャンパ頃にする人曰く
ホンダ
複数人でが8月触って楽しいものであるキャンプをあえて一人でやることによってそこ
に孤独の楽しさを見いだすことができるという点がソロキャンプの魅力であり
ブームの理由であるらしいのです
なるほど確かに私も一人旅というソロキャンプと似たようなことをやります
ただ単にねこう俺がぼっちなだだけだろうと言われてしまいそうですけども
で一人旅でしかできないから仕方なくやってるわけじゃなくて
もちろん大勢での力は何でもやったことがあるしその全てがとても楽しいものでした
実際データがんですかときはそのでデータを出しておきます
旅行代理店最大手の jtb が2017年度のコロナだと2020年度のやつあてに
なりませんので2017年度に実施した
一人旅に関するアンケートによれば一人旅をしている人の中で同行者がいなかったとか
同公社の予定が合わない同行者の献花にあったとかで仕方なく消極的な
揺れ一人旅をしていた4割に満たず6割強の人が自ら好んで一人旅をしているという
ことが分かりますよって一人旅をしたりソロキャンプをしている人というのは少なから
ず仕方なくじゃなくて自分の意思でやってるわけです
しかし私はここで大きな違和感を抱きました特に強く違和感を覚えたのは先ほど見た
ソロキャンパーの良い件
あれは読売新聞の記事見たのですがこのソロキャンパー孤独を楽しむという表現です
孤独という一見ネガティブに見えること言葉を楽しむというポジティブな言葉でもって
補い
まるで一つの遊びのようなものに昇華させている不思議な表現です
まずこの孤独という言葉自体も4位なのでたとえば以上しの36%を占めると言われて
いる孤独死という表現があるようにネガティブな表現がコンテナがレッツ
プロチャンプの購読の楽しさとかあるいは孤独のグルメなんていう番組目があるように
少しだけ言葉に明日にスパイスを加えてあげれば突然ポジティブな表現にさは害して
しまうのです
私の違和感の元をたどるとこの孤独の意味をがネガティブからポジティブに変わる起点
スパイスが一応体が分からないということからきているんですがさすがにこれだと抽象
的ていて8日が無いでしょうからもう少し違和感を具体的な例で理解してもらおうと
思います
例えば私が今ことで大きくて受けて皆さん僕は孤独です誰か助けてください
といってもまあ恐らく多くの人は信じないでしょ馬鹿にしてるのかと言い開催覚えて人
もいるかもしれません
まあ確かに
ですがもしお子の私が本当に明日自殺してしまい遺書に僕は孤独だった
僕はただそれはみんな必死んしてしまっていただけなのに誰も理解してくれなかったん
だと書いてあったとしたらどうでしょ
確かにこの人は大声で孤独だと主張していました口調が明らかに孤独な人それじゃない
だろうと云わいう文も悲観的な見方だと言われればそれまでです
ということです
的には皆さんにあるでしょうか
結論から言えばこれは皆さんに結論キスだけ皆さん責任ありません
私がこれを第三者目線で見てもこの人に里は防ぎようがないなと考えるでしょ
もっと具体的なりに行きますこの観光地は北海道旅行では知る人と知る穴場スポットと
して有名です
こういう文書が普通にグループトラベルのややめとけや海や観光ハンディブックとかに
書いてあるわけですね
有名な anabas 取ったということでしょうかねしかもあなたがたった今雑誌上
でベラベラ喋ったせいで穴場でなくなってしまいます知る人と知るがみんな知ってるに
なりますけど大丈夫ですか
となく疑ってしまいますさらに曲た形に行きましょう
空港でこういう金髪の外国人から申し訳ありません大変センサーが私は日本があまり
上手に話すことができませんと話しかけられたら
っ子ラジ
次見事な日本語を話していらっしゃると完封してしまうと思います
これで私の栄冠を少しは共感していただけたでしょうか以上の3つの話にはすべて共通
点があります
簡単に言えばそもそも論というやつで本当に孤独な人はそもそも孤独だとマリ伝えられ
ないし本当の穴場スポットはそもそも自分から名前だって占い師
ほんと日本語がしゃべれない人はそもそもにを期する伝えることができません
要はこれらの事柄というのは周りにその事をしてい
直的に主張している人は本当にその言葉に当てはまる人ものではないとされ実際そう
いうことが多いので
逆に本当にその事柄に当てはまる人を見つけ出すのは非常に難しいというものです
これをソロキャンプ一人ため話戻すとこうなりますソロキャンプをする者たちが孤独を
好み孤独を楽しいものなのであれば
果たしてそういう人たちが自分から饒舌にですね孤独が楽しめるか皆ソロキャンプ c
4へそのキャンプ行こうねと周囲に話してもらったりするのでしょうか
またそれによっていこう
多くの楽しさを感じるブームが巻き起こるというのはあるのでしょうか
本当にブームが巻き起こっているかどうか毎年日本オートキャンプ協会が発行している
キャンプアクション
2020年度を見ればわかります号から僕は2020年度の数字を言いますけどあれが
7800円とはが高いのでこのデータ2019年になってますすいませんアンケートの
結果キャンプ同行者人数がゼロに
つまりソロキャンプをしている人はキャンプ全体の同行者人数ランキングで4
いいさらにキャンプ場の51て7%がソロキャンプやる人が増えたと回答しています
よってブームが起きているというのはウソではないようです
ここから単純に考えてみるとこの子を楽しみそのキャンプが人気になったということは
孤独を求める人が増えたはずなのですがネットれソロチャンプについて検索してみると
ソロキャンプに暇つぶし7000みたいなサイトが割と穂が出てきます
しかもその中に sns を触るギターの選択肢は平然というされてるんです
あなたは孤独お楽しみにそのキャンプに行ったんじゃないのか
ss start
どうせ的しまいたくなります
本当にこの人たちは孤独が楽しくでそのキャンプにっていうのでしょうか
つまりネガティブな孤独が何かスパイスがかかってポジティブな孤独に変化したのでは
なくて初めからこれは全然違うひちゅりーの孤独でそのキャンパーその本当の孤独とは
別の形が違う孤独を楽しみいっていうのはないかというのが私の考えです
その上で私の仮説実は孤独ねに周囲の物があってみられている孤独とみられていない
孤独がありそのチャンプの場合は見られている孤独かを見出すことができる
この2州や別にこれ以外にも一時的な孤独永続的な孤独とか
5体がある言葉を炊いてのは帰れるところですけど母体がある孤独母体がない孤独の
ようにいくらでもラベル付けないですが今回はこれでいきましょう
おそらくポジティブな意味のことが見られていることでありネガティブな意味のことが
見られていない孤独だろうと考えました
まず見られていないことを考えましょうそもそもそのみられていない孤独を抱える人は
僕がコードクレスト回り行ったり術がないように見えます
なぜなみられていないからですというか伝えるスレがあったとしても伝えないことの方
が多いと思います
なぜかなぜこのタイプの孤独を感じる人が孤独を周囲に伝えないのか説明するために
非常に難しく
は聞いてこの孤独を経験したこと
がある人でも言語化が難しいでしょう聞いて無理やり何か説明するなら今誰かた2人
こういうこういう長く熊谷て僕はこの人ともこのクマ友達です誰から2人として相手に
自分が今俺孤独に襲われてるんだよね
とっきー出すかどうかです二人でいるのに自分が孤独を感じていると主張するのは大変
難しく
しかも相手がそれほど信頼を受ける相手が僕にとってこの子は本当に信頼できるのかと
いうのはよくわからないはずです
さあ
郷土の例を引用するなら北海道旅行の神の穴バー自ら穴場スポットとして雑誌言い出さ
ないように
とにかく表に見える形で出てくることは少ないと考えます
おそらく皆さん中でこういった考えを持ってる人はさっきのこのクマのように自分は
孤独です何度も何度も大声者っていうのは多少あったがな面を持っているんだなと思い
ますうわこのようなあーもうそうだもう一つだというと
忙しいという島の一言は忙しいは忙しいと主張するという傾向があります
ではこのような孤独とが忙しいとかで食べのこと場合マーリン主張すればするほど新
矯正が
藩兵下がってきてるとても厄介な表現ですこのみられていないことが私は真の孤独と
考えることにします
では逆に時の孤独とは何かそれが見られていることですたとえソロキャンプに行っ
てようが一人旅に行ってようが現地では白い南下した停戦 s にアップする
つまり外界との交信は立たずに自分が一人で孤独に行動しているところを見せ
ことが楽しいと周りに伝えて回るこれらの講談見られていることとかを満たします
言うなればらーメニューカンデラブランドご案内
にいるような気分でして外から中にスープの立場できませんが放置してるとどんどん
同じようなブラナーが集まって自分の油なぁもう来てある
しかし夫なればなるほどは同市のは中心から中心は遠ざかってしまうのでお互い見える
程度の距離に大きさを調整値玉にくっついて一つになったりする
私はこの見上げていることゴルァーいう的なことを言うとさらにラベリングすることに
しました
や別に本当はもっと良い例えがあったと思うし
正直これ笑じゃあぺラードですなんでこんな表現した not a 4原稿チェックと
いうので言われたんですけれども
まあそれについてはこういう深夜テンションです今ここで孤独について真の孤独時の
孤独を再定義し
前に話したソロキャンパー達が楽しんでいる別の孤独というのは木の子ど
すなわち来的な孤独と結論付けました
本当はこれで終わっても良かったのですがここまで書き上げた後この企画の名前である
ウッド x の youtube チャンネルを見たらあまりにも交渉の話を水で
ビビってしまいましたのでもうちょっと僕バランスをにしましょう
さっき人がソロキャンプや一人旅をしたがるのはラーいう的な言葉を満たすためだと
結論付けましたがではなぜ人々はそうやって来的な孤独を求めるでしょうか
この疑問について私は2つの仮説をひねり出しましたひとつ目の仮説は来週的な孤独
そのものを求めているのではなくそこからの脱却を楽しんでいるという説ですつまり
このタイプのことが周囲から未来というので逆には自分の積極的に外海が
connect していく姿勢を見せれば簡単に孤独から脱却できます
そのため確かに口ではことが楽しいと言っていますけども
孤独
そのものが楽しいのではなくて自身の行動で孤独から脱却することに楽しむ抱いてるん
じゃないかという説です
これは例えばもうも来れない人が目を閉じているときに早く女を開けた光が差し込んで
きるという時お茶にいています
これに対して二つ目の仮説疑似カリスマ性を得ると書いてありますが5月性格の悪い
考え方です
この仮説のヒント甘いというジャクソンにあります彼は世界でもっとも多くのアルバム
売り上げて名実共に音楽界のトップに上り詰めましたが同時にからひどい孤独感に
悩まされとにかく友達を干していたと家族を含め多くの人が証言していました
楽しいネットでスーパースター
孤独と調べると多くの場合彼かあるいはフレディーマーキュリーが嫉妬します
別に彼らだけでなくても芸能界や音楽会などのスーパースターの多くはそのあまりの
カリスマ性から崇拝されかえって本人の孤独感を増幅させたり孤立してしまうことが
多いように見えるのですつまり人々からああいう的なみられていることが求めている
理由はこのようなスーパースターたちが感じた
神の言葉の疑似体験をすることにより
いう的なカリスマ性あるありに一つの快感を得るという人間の根底に流れるダークな
心情の権化なのではないかという説です
もちろんスーパースターたちのことが真の孤独砂地みられていないことです
本人たちは自分が孤独だと一言も発しませんがそれ以外の場所でも影響力雨に絶大な
ため勝手に回り一人子得であることがバレてしまいます
それに対し一般人というのは思っ
たり他人に見られていないので自分が孤独だとある程度まあになってるしなければなり
ません
その主はメディあったり sns だったりと対応ですがこうやって来的なほど稼いさ
れこれはどちらかといえば一般人ではなくてちょっとした
インフルエンサーのた人たちが口をするようになったのではないでしょうか
一応具体例を見ておきます電車つまり孤独からの脱却を楽しんでるタイプ一般人は
もちろんアニメに登場する架空の人物たちが貯まります
カメラ勝手に我々部外者を回しいるだけなので本人達当たり前ですけど
校舎の7回様て犬疑似だけ欲しいとかそういう言葉も何も考えてないと思います
逆にこのようにマイナススーパー星が書いてありますけどこういう聞かれてもいないの
にやたらと孤独を主張して人というのは短いさせを得たいというタイプが多いです
まあこれ一般人にはちょっと当てはまらですね
なのはどのネガティブな人たちが申し訳ないですもちろん私はこの来的なことが満たし
たいというのは人間の自然欲求だてしかるべきものだし
先ほどから上げてきたソロキャンプ等の確かに魅力あるものです
しかし私はこのライン的な孤独のメカニズムを決めくれた会社で唱えることによりその
他捉えることにより逆に真の孤独を感じている人を救い出す手がかりを得ることが
できるはずだと考えています
大
の場合みられていない真の孤独を感じている人は自分の口から自分が孤独であるという
ことは言わないことが多いと先を述べました
そのため真の孤独を感じて人達を救い出すには自動的な対応ではなく能動的な大量臨ま
なければならないと思うのです
よく学校には心理カウンセラーがいる部屋が用意されていたり
アンケートにあなた孤独を感じていますかというようなオナ配られた
するのですがまぁ完全に無意味とは言わないし救い焦るごとくもあるのですが深刻に神
の国抱えてる人というのはこのような受動的な態度が本人たちから言えばあの極悪
ゲスト主張しなければいけないで能動的なカエルですがこういったフィルター写真の
孤独を抱えている人を救い出せないように思います
こういうフィルターに引っかからなかった有名人が突然舌とうとうを得たりして
関係者の突然のことでびっくりしています交友関係を確立してるには見えなかったのに
というコメントがテレビ画面に映し出されのもよくある話です
神の子とご飯中人を探し出すのはとても難しいのです
能動的な対策というのは例えば家に孤独を感じていないか自分に何かできることはない
かというような声かけを見つけますけども
相手が別神の言葉を求めてなければこれはただに高圧的な友人に成り下がってしまい
ます
これはつまり北海道旅行の神の穴場スポットを見つけるのと同じくらい難しく
例えば現れおいて美味いか不味いかの二択のように能動的に来
5-1サン孤独な人を探し出すというのはし常にリスクが伴います
この問題の解決策はいまだ見つかっていませんが私は少なくとも自動的に与えるいつ
までたっても真の孤独を抱える人というのは作り出せないはずだと考えましたそして逆
に今孤独を感じる人たち
その気持ちを少しでも誰かに吐露できる状態なら十分そこから脱却できる可能性があり
ますよということを
伝えて伝えたいです
誰かなこの後誰かラーメンと一緒にラーメン食べに行きましょう以上です
[拍手]